voilà patrick bruel société
je lui ai dit ok
eli lilly
c'est irrésistible c'est normal alors
est ce que finalement c'est pas une
façon patrick bruel de dire vous le
petit pied noir toi aussi paris tu m'as
pris dans tes bras est ce que c'est pas
une très bonne question c'est le sait
bravo il y avait longtemps qu'on
attendait ça bravo mais c'est vrai c'est
de dire c'est de dire voilà voilà voilà
ce qu'est la france aussi voilà voilà
voilà cette france qu'on chante la
plupart de ses chansons sont des
chansons qui sont écrites entre 36 et 38
36 utile de le rappeler c'est un réveil
populaire énorme et une montée de
l'extrême droite assez assez forte en 34
35 sursaut populaire fantastique
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de chansons
beaucoup de créations et puis un certain
laxisme politique qui nous amène jusqu'à
la guerre donc sans vouloir faire de
parallèle
donc ça va vite mais ça peut nous amener
à une certaine vigilance
je pense que les gens vous fait une
tournée cet été je vais chanter ça sur
scène dressée pour me faire plaisir
j'avais très envie de de prolonger ce
moment non j'avais c'est vrai que la
scène me manque vite quand je là quand
je vois quand je la quitte donc je
retrouvais n'importe quelle excuse pour
repartir sur la non quoi ça fait un an
même pas même pas oui je n'étais pas non
mais c'est à peu près ce que de route
est déjà été pas mais j'avais très envie
et c'est vrai que dalle et d'accompagner
cet album faire on va faire que des
petites salles que dès que des petits
endroits que des petits lieux c'est et
c'est une petite tournée au mois de
juillet comme ça on va se faire plaisir
avec ses musiciens on va aimer vraiment
ça à la fois content et quand on vise la
même scène et quand on reçoit ce que je
reçois c'est non non mais quoi quand
vous arrêtez pas à tourner effectivement
l'été dernier deux films cette saison
les jolies choses de gilles paquet
brenner le lait de la tendresse humaine
de dominique cabrera théâtre à la
rentrée
le limier pièces extraordinaires delhi
le film de mankiewicz cela d'ailleurs
avec jacques weber avec gilbert
absolument pas d'histoire avec cette fin
incroyable
alors à part sa taille à roland garros
et la coupe du monde à boucher s'est
vraiment mis en garde ensemble est alors
demain demain les matchs de football un
match de gala au parc des princes au
profit de l'association enfants afghans
dont le but est de faire un hôpital pour
les enfants de kaboul
c'est une association qui est menée par
muriel robin et marine jacquemin
c'est à 18 heures au parc des princes
alors il y aura là il ya patrick timsit
le voir jouer au ballon avec inde pour
soutenir et elie semoun laurent ruquier
qui joue au ballon aussi ppda pierre
palmade nagle ira famille ce rallye marc
lavoine michel drucker
lorànt deutsch francis cabrel dany boon
nous serment des lots est laurent boyer
j'existe et vous donc voilà oui on sera
là on va 100 ça on va s'amuser
ouais c'est jouer les uns contre les
autres je vais pas contre une vraie
équipe je pense que ça vaut mieux pour
nous eh bien le poker
alors ça le poker un des meilleurs
joueurs du monde patrie british champion
du monde et cette année à cause des
élections présidentielles vous êtes
parti que le 7 mai et donc je n'ai pas
pu participer à tous les concours c'est
pour ça que vous n'êtes que vice
champion du monde de poker
j'ai eu la chance d'aller assez loin
dans la compétition cette année bien
passé et puis en finale j'ai fait j'ai
péché par excès de excès de confiance
sérieusement il faut quand même avoir un
sacré mental pour être champion du monde
vice champion du monde de poker quand
même c'est extraordinaire ça il faut
fait bluffeur il faut être sûr de soi il
faut avoir plein de qualités sont pas la
qualité essentielle pour un jour de
poker le croque la qualité essentielle
c'est là que je serais plutôt
l'analytique comportements sains et la
patience beaucoup de patience et puis
bon évidemment connaître un peu de jeu
mais le bluff en question dont tout le
monde parle comme si le bloc était
totalement liés au poker le bloc est
plus lié dans les parties dans les
partis on est partis n'ont jamais fumé
l'oreille c'est quand même temps sont
remis à quoi on fait sa ba sur un
tournoi comme comme un tournant avec
gaza se passe sur deux jours donc il ya
une ça commence à midi
le premier jour ça commence à midi avec
200 ou 300 joueurs jusqu'à ce qu'on soit
plus que neuf pour la finale qui aura
lieu le lendemain donc ça peut aller
2010 jusqu'à 3 4 heures du matin suite
on essaie d'aller se coucher de se
préparer mentalement pour une finale et
on arrive à 14h à neuf et ça sera quand
on sera plus à sortir a plus qu'un seul
but gagner de l'argent ou vous perdez de
l'argent avec ça ah ben quand tu as
battu campagne actuelle ouais et quand
tu perds tu paies repos puisque c'est
une coutume et un teint d'investissement
au départ qui est pour tout le monde le
même tu peux pas mettre plus et c'est
donc pour tous est une source de revenue
mais finalement ça pourrait l'être est
veuf ça laisse donc la désavantage l'un
des avantages que j'ai sur les autres
joueurs qui sont tous des professionnels
c'est que comme comme je ne suis pas
professionnel que je ne joue pas pour le
gain j'y joue plus pour le protéger je
suis plus relâché par rapport à ça et
déjà blindé donc là pas le stress de
perdre voilà faire plus que je voulais
dire bien maintenant je vais opposer la
question grave
patrick bruel aulas c'est quoi la
question grave elle est très grave n'est
pas un jingle accra question gran via un
jingle
bon alors c'est vrai que j'allais vous
marier j'ai entendu dire non je vais en
parler je les ai entendus dire parce que
la rumeur mais il me relever le jour où
je l'aurai décidé enfin de vous l'auront
décidé en tout cas vous serez les
premiers informés vous rassurez vous
c'est pas le genre de choses que j'ai
envie de cacher je pense aller à votre
mari elle pour l'instant c'est à l'ordre
du jour c'est pas à l'ordre du jour